- I joined LAPD in 1981,
was there during Rodney King,
was there during the riots.
Los Angeles was really the breeding ground
of how to do things right
and how to do things wrong.
I have seen a lot, and I've learned a lot.
But I will tell you that school policing
was a whole different
eye-opening experience for me.
- So the mindset around
cops in this community,
if I had to give you an honest opinion,
it's not a positive one.
We obviously need police to
protect our cities and citizens,
so I definitely think that
there's a place in schools,
but it has to be a very honest
and working relationship.
- I started to understand
that there are pieces
to the law enforcement tool box
that are much more
successful than that gun,
or the Taser, or the OC spray.
The biggest weapon that the
police officer is armed with
that they don't use is their mouth,
that mouth, that ability
to have a discussion.
So for me, that SEL component
is really, really important.
When I went in to roll call,
and I sat the officers down,
you'd have thought I was
speaking French to them.
Most police officers across the country
never understand the complexities
of what this person is going through,
understanding life and
all the other nuances
to why you're there handling that call.
- The typical calls I go
to day to day are fights,
burglaries, and a major, major calls I go
to are sexual assaults.
People bring guns to
school, knives to school.
It's dangerous.
I grab one cup of coffee,
and then I head to my assigned school,
which is Castlemont High
School in East Oakland.
- Historically, over the last few years,
Castlemont has not been the
first choice of schools.
This has been more like the last option.
The neighborhood around this area is still
one of the highest in crime in the city.
Many of our students go through a lot.
The challenges that they face
to get up in the morning
and be at school, focused,
we try not to make excuses for them.
We try to teach them to be able
to utilize the folks that are here,
and it's a work in progress.
- The chief of police always told us,
take 10 seconds, breathe,
see what you got,
assess it, and then we'll go from there.
I've always taken that into mind,
and maybe I'll talk to the students
and find out the story.
I try to share my experiences with them
on some of the same experience
that they're going through.
I try to get them help.
I try to counsel them.
- Although he wears a uniform
and his job is a police officer,
we view Officer Singh as
a Castlemont staff member,
partly because of his efforts
to really build relationships
with folks here.
And it really has changed the landscape
of how many of our students
think of the police.
- My friendship with Officer
Singh has changed my outlook.
Just remembering that police
officers are people too.
He's just like me.
He's a pretty cool guy.
I do believe that he makes a
great effort to meet people
and get to know them
on a one-to-one level.
- I believe the approach that we take
here at Castlemont is a true example
of how police and schools
can work together,
where the focus is not,
okay, let me be punitive,
and let me punish kids,
but more so, how can I support kids?
- If you can't understand and
have empathy for these kids
and these families, you're not
going to be very successful.
And that has nothing to do with Oakland.
It could be Los Angeles,
it could be anywhere.
Going to radio calls and arresting people
and throwing them in jail is not working,
and we all know that.
And I would not have
said that to you in 1982.